foreign
let's go to David in Clearfield Utah
what's up brother d
hey John you can hear me okay yeah
absolutely what's up man
um so I got into a I guess a texting
argument with
um one of my wife's family members
um who I'm fairly close with
um
basically I was trying to figure out
what was going on and he told me
in a nutshell that I'm super
argumentative I turn everything into a
competition and even went as far as to
say is like I'm emotionally abusive
towards my wife
and so I kind of sat down and had a
conversation with my wife about it and
she I basically asked I said you know is
that true am I like that and she said
not all the time but yeah
and um
she said that she doesn't feel like I'm
emotionally abusive because she's been
in those relationships before
um but she does she did say that like I
do things that are hurtful and and I
raise my voice a lot and stuff like that
um
I've had I've been told this before by
other people in my past I know it's true
but I'm not sure how I can be I guess
more self-aware self-aware of
how I'm talking and how I'm behaving
um
man that's hard to hear
yeah
um first first I was man recommend
strongly never ever ever get into text
fights with anybody nothing no one ever
wins there because you missed so much of
the
um
body language and body posture and
people say they lob grenades via text if
they wouldn't in person so
um but anyway we're here now
um what led to the fight
um I just had
I felt like things were getting really
tense between us and I wasn't sure why
and so I just kind of I had texted him
because we've been texting and I just
basically said hey you know I don't know
what's been going on lately you seem
like you've been more upset with me
lately you know if I've done something
you know just tell me I'll I'll try to
make it right and stuff
but this didn't come out of the blue
something happened what happened
um just
I guess just
[Music]
we kind of banter back and forth we'll
joke with each other but lately it's
been like really hurtful and like really
mean things
um that you're saying to him or he's
saying to you
yeah he's been saying to me and I I
thought maybe I was making it up a
little bit but then my wife started to
notice it too and she brought it up yeah
and so I was like okay maybe I should
try to air out the laundry here a little
bit and figure out what's going on okay
um so a couple things here one is
it feels like your wife well number one
good for your brother-in-law because he
doesn't like the way some guy is
treating his sister right so I'm glad he
said I wish he'd come up and directly
said something to you instead of being
passive aggressive and throwing little
cheap Jabs here and there oh she'd come
up and had a direct confrontation with
you not in a fist fight kind of way but
in a hey don't talk to my sister like
this or why are you I'm struggling you
said you were really close to him and so
you you deserve that conversation that
he didn't have but it's out there now it
also sounds like your sister has not
felt safe talking to you about stuff but
has circled around and gone and talked
to her brother about you
um how did that conversation go with
your wife like she confirmed some of the
stuff he said and she tried to soften it
a little bit because she's got to live
with you he doesn't
um
what was the nature of that conversation
did she feel was there a relief that
she's finally get to say this stuff out
loud was there a sense of
trepidation she was nervous to tell you
stuff
I don't I don't know if she was nervous
um we had had kind of this conversation
before earlier in a relationship
and I I thought that I had been doing
better because it hadn't come up in a
long time but then it obviously it
ruined its ugly head again okay
um but I felt like the conversation
actually went really well it really
started a healthy conversation and so
I've been trying to do things to work on
you know myself but okay I felt like the
nature of the conversation was actually
really good okay
so whenever we say things like
overbearing or emotionally abusive or
too competitive
um those those are grenade words not
helpful to me so be specific you said
you know what your brother-in-law said
is true and what your wife said is true
so give me some examples where are you
competitive to the point that you know
you're crossing a line
well that's kind of my issue is I don't
know and I asked my wife I asked her I
said you know can you give me a specific
example of the time I've been too
competitive and I haven't really been
able to get a clear answer on that all
right so let's dig in when somebody's
got a like a story or a one time I did
this are you a guy that goes oh yeah
well one time I or is that you
um are you a one-upper
I I don't know yes
I mean you know
like can somebody tell a story about the
scariest time they almost got in a car
wreck and you just sit there in silence
or do you have to say oh yeah one time I
got in a car wreck yes or no I probably
I probably do that yeah okay do you do
you talk about money who's making what
at family events yes your brother how
much he's making I I no I try not to
talk money I don't quite those
conversations well where do you where
else would you somebody else might
consider you competitive
are you like uh Meet the Fockers or do
you like get crazy at uh at volleyball
games you know what I mean family
volleyball games or whatever like
where's this competitive thing coming up
with sports I think I'm fairly
competitive okay I'm like like we went
bowling together and I was having a good
game I was getting really excited and I
wasn't trying to be mean about it you
know and I was trying to like cheer
everybody else on too but I I could see
where like in that situation I probably
was pretty overbearing
okay so be specific what is you know
kind of probably pretty overbearing what
like be specific were you yelling at
people or you like suck it were you like
in people's faces pouring beer on them
like what were you doing
just just being loud and kind of
rambunctious
um
clearly and nobody else was
um yeah I think that's fair okay all
right
um what about
emotionally abusive
your wife confirmed that she said I
wouldn't call you abusive but yeah you
go too far and you said you raised your
voice are you someone who yells a lot
um yeah I have kind of a loud
personality okay and
that's the thing that kind of worries me
the most I think is because like
I'm not I'm not being mean I guess when
I raise my voice but
it comes across mean
okay
um I'm easily excited so any regardless
of the mood or anything I'll raise my
voice is this it's something I've always
done I guess so hear me say that yelling
at somebody and anger's abuse
so if you get mad if you get angry you
get frustrated and you start yelling
yell at your wife yell at your house
yield your brother-in-law you yell in
the house at somebody and your wife's
sitting there if you've got little kids
in the house and you're yelling
as trauma that hurts people
if you're just a loud guy and this is
the pot talking of the kettle here I'm a
loud guy too here's what was an
important
um shape-shifting moment for me
that
my intention often doesn't matter
that if I want to really love people
especially my wife but if I want to love
my friends if I want to love my
community if I want to love Ben and
Kelly and and everybody in the in the
booth
then I'm responsible for making sure I
can be heard and making sure I'm a safe
place to be around and most that goes
very counter-cultural to talk like that
because the culture says you just be you
bro and everybody can adjust that's
stupid
if I if I am too much
then the world will respond by leaving
me completely alone
and so I value relationships and other
people's feeling safe around me and so I
work hard to bring it down a notch and
bring it down a notch for me is bringing
it down many notches for most people
because I'm a lot right
um there's something here
if I can be honest with you I don't like
how you're being kind of aloof
and like look I I don't know man I guess
it's just maybe
like you've got two people who love you
and that you love in your life telling
you that you hurt them
and you say yeah I believe them but I
don't I just don't know man I'm not
buying it
I don't know if it's a protective thing
you've set up or just kind of a way you
get through life
be honest with me man
I
I'm just not very self-aware I guess I I
I don't know
I know you don't want me to be aloof and
I'm not trying to be I just I don't know
what the actual issue is and why I tend
to
I guess get loud in certain situations
or to get competitive or argumentative I
don't know okay
so one of the greatest gifts a person in
your situation can have and I've been
there too most people have where they're
being a certain way they're acting a
certain way and they they don't have a
full grasp on it
one of the greatest gifts you can have
is people that you trust in your life to
be honest with you
and so here's your homework assignment
you ready
it is to number one create a written
dialogue with your wife
either she's not able to come up with
with answers really fast
and she wants to be more thoughtful in
her answers or she just comes to answers
a little bit more organically a little
more slowly her answers are more thought
through or she doesn't feel safe
speaking them out loud
often in that situation people will
write him down
or offer to say hey I'd love to go to a
marriage Council I want to be better at
this and I'm I'm I'm I've created a
world where you don't feel safe and it
makes me sick to my stomach that I'm
doing that to the one person who I love
more than anybody else would you go talk
to somebody with me
um and let her a therapist's job is to
create a safe environment for people to
have hard conversations
and so hopefully so a neutral third
party would be able to create that
environment where she could then speak
um have you ever been aggressive with
her
um as far as
physically or just verbally both
um I've never laid a hand on her like
ever okay um
um I've never I've never cussed at her
I've never we've never gotten it's like
a screaming match like we've had
arguments but we've never like screamed
at each other or anything like that all
right
um so the next thing you do is I want
you to have a conversation with your
brother-in-law in person tell them hey I
want to go out for drinks wanna go for
coffee whatever I'm buying
um
I need some help start that way I need
some help
and I would tell him hey number one
sorry for doing this over text I should
never have texted you this stuff in the
first place I should have just met with
you in person I'm sorry number two
your sister means the absolute world to
me I love her more than anything else
and it hurts to find out from somebody I
respect and I love too
that you feel like I'm abusive that I'm
too competitive I'm hard to be around
will you help me because I don't see it
and I really need some clarity in my
life
um that sort of humility is going to
open you up and I want you to take a pin
and something to write on when he's
talking and write that stuff down and
like you did with your wife I said can
you give me this example man
and if he's right or let me put it this
way this isn't the conversation to go
yeah but this is a conversation for you
just to listen and maybe you tell him
that I'm not going to refute anything
you say today I just want to listen
I'm about healing this and I clearly
have some work I need to do on me and I
need somebody that I trust to help me be
reflective because I'm missing it
and hopefully he's the person of
integrity and he'll have that
conversation do you think you will
yeah I definitely think okay and then
the third one so you got your wife
you've got your brother-in-law those are
the two who've been involved here do you
have a
Mentor a boss that you trust or a team
leader at your office that you trust or
a couple of friends that you've known
for a long time that you trust
I do have a friend that I could reach
out to I would love for you to reach out
and say hey all right here's hard
conversation I've gotten some feedback
from some folks in my life that I love
my wife and that I'm too much that I'm
overbearing I'm overly competitive I'm
even like one of them called me
emotionally abusive like I need you to
be honest with me and I've had this
conversation with friends of mine in the
past
Trevor Craig Todd Kevin Michael I can
name them in in my life who I've gone to
Jean Doyle I've talked to folks and um
have asked for some direct feedback and
um it was really hard to hear in certain
seasons of my life and it was a great
great gift
um your friends might lie to you and be
like nah bro no no no like it's all good
forget them screw that guy hopefully
they'll be honest like yeah dude you
know it and here's the thing my buddies
when I've asked for feedback or hey I'm
struggling with this am I not seeing
this right
um dude they're like are you serious how
do you not know that every time we play
a game everybody gets out of the way
because you're you know I mean or
whatever the thing would be with you but
they're real direct with me real direct
and it's changed my life and so at this
point if you can honestly look in the
mirror and say I believe they're telling
the truth but I don't see it then your
job is to go with people who will be
reflective with you and will tell you
the truth and your job isn't to fight it
or refute it it's to lean into it
um and then here's what we're gonna do
you're gonna have a pile of information
when you get done all right David you're
gonna have a bunch of stuff here like
this and then that and then that
then you're going to be about working on
it so I'm gonna do you a favor I'm gonna
give you a copy of own your past change
your future it's my new book coming out
I'm gonna give you a copy of it because
it's going to walk you through what you
do next
one of the cornerstones of that book is
you have to own reality I didn't want
this but here's what I where I am either
what I'm doing what's been done to me
here's where I am
and then what the heck do I do now and
so it'll walk you out so hang on the
line I'll send you a copy of it um
and then you might need to call somebody
you might need to call somebody whether
reach out to better help and they pump
it into your house for therapy or you
reach out to a local therapist in your
community you may need to sit down and
say I've got a long history of this
behavior my guess is
um
you getting loud is a way to keep people
off of you it's a distance it's a
protective measure your overly
competitiveness is because somebody told
you somewhere that you don't have a lot
of value unless you're in first place
and you have created value for yourself
by being loud by being the guy and all
the stuff and I win on your face
and your way you protect yourself ends
up let me say like the way you have
developed coping mechanisms mechanisms
to take care of yourself you end up
forcing people away from you which just
reinforces your coping mechanism so you
get louder and louder and louder and
then people get further and further away
from you until one or two of them
finally snaps like your brother-in-law
did
so what you're gonna have to do is learn
new coping mechanisms and usually coping
mechanisms start with you looking in the
mirror and saying I'm worth something
better than this I'm worth something
more than this
because I'm tired of being loud I'm
tired of being the guy's got to be oh
I'm tired to be that guy
I want to be able to just sit and hold
my wife's hand I want to be quiet I want
to be loved I still like laughing I
still like being silly I still like
being you know the bell of the ball but
oh
I'm worth more than this
so give it a shot brother give it a shot
we'll be in your corner right I want you
to reach back out to us let me know how
that call went with your brother-in-law
with that conversation you're going to
have that that in person let me know how
that goes and we'll feature you back on
the show because people are going to be
wondering what that conversation is like
and what the follow-up is and I'll keep
walking alongside you that's my
commitment